в тему роті на спортивну вас
ходила містер і завали не ви
університету за модель я козак ладана в
законі пропущу святу всім уроки в
польше засовується на практиці
ідеологія ті йому дали польова в тому
щоб більше вигляд молодість а види
ручного разу ходила державного замовлення
зінчука боку ранту ватою бюджетні місця
для microsoft для на з найсильніших
абітурієнтів там у вас на модельку
будова на такому ж нам ще псам і
закладено в результаті
абітурієнти we keep вдалося надутого g
нічого вище на відразу не відчувати
реальність
ви спочатку сяке кисть на місяць ержан але
замовте мікел термо в тій же ніші
юніверса так і ким джон замкнуту на
практиці великої червової держави
кабінет міністрів означає скільки
місяці затіють меншу спеціальністю
держава готова фінансово ти скільки
місяць бюджетного замовлення виділяється
на тут же ин джу спеціальність улюблену
добрі кладу три спеціальності, наприклад
спеціальність траву та кучеряво виділяючи
по дну кілька суміш у постанові
заперечив це і за новими і до
прикладу без маму спеціальність
менеджмент
у них тримала ви спочатку з кількою
містер рівного замовлення та донатті
спеціальності якщо тіло університет
зупиняти устілкою максимуму
напоготові прийняте на ту спеціальність
максимум може бутони білий ніжно 25
висотки пак і пурим не обдурив і мороку
що позначають максимальну опцію
університету по ви не були ви значить
скільки в і напоготові скільки він зник
про можна snapchat за бюджетним за
молодиком і
в ціль показати не може вбитим нижче 25
і 40 плюс 25 висотки видно ну лаврова на
практиці те звучання означає, що сума
цифр максимальних опціях і загибель
фініш загальна кільки змісти до видачі на
для конкретної спеціальності з
моральності конкурентність владна
куляїв тому щоб наповнити максимуму
видно і преференції абітурієнтів для
для нас поступатися в абітурієнта та
капюшоном абітурієнт вранці та
рекомендацію на дріжджах тому
полум'я пропустимо абітурієнта е4 заяви
великих 2 на спеціальність право дає
душі високий профіль не бали на ці
душі складаного по трап це якоб рацію
система шлях від коли складу перебираючи
ж абітурієнт споживаючи в максимальній
опції ви значення для конкретного
універсидад але прокладок всі у них стоять
ви означає, що win mag саму може прийнято
на спеціальності право сто чоловік
бармену за сама перевіряє, що ти
поправляєш у стогін красти їх ви тому
університеті я хочу це споживаєш у
число ста найкраще складу перевіряє
обидва за одним пріоритетом
споживаєш
в 100 nike росію наприклад ви значущих
я камок для іншого університету
литого іншого priori дату
якось щось сюди споживаєш якщо тіло
система перевіряє що ти споживаєш в
число найкраще для тіней спеціальності в
стилом всюди виводиться абітурієнт з
різьблених
факультатив зоряних у нього розсипати їх
позначається чити по стежках до числа
найкраща на шахті їй спеціальність для
спеціальності права з трап це було
навіть склад на там ще профіт не бали
їдуть дуже високою у душу престижних
університетах він встановлений без 6 8 10
балів загалом про Україну у всі ми ж
стану було близько стоять тут це
самий біль там у його ситуації
кудись потром полеглих максимум
максимально всіх у нього ростуть
від розумна
споживаєш число на карачках витівку
спеціальністю в такому разі катування складу
перевіряє обидва витратним пріоритетом їх
рахунок витрати перетворять visa in шую
спеціальністю складаємося і перевіряючи і ким
чен нам ти споживаєш сюди щось
споживаєш максимальний опціях за
іншу спеціальністю за спеціальну
менеджмент простягни бали та високими
алена багатий чоловік нижче
спеціальністю про ми пропустимо ти
споживаєш максимальну опцію
універсал 5 сидить і пройти priori
після цілісного вже такий актив по
передніх лопатках складі перевіряючи ж ти
споживаєш живе число найкраще до речі
нею спеціальністю так що ти споживаєш
у такому лопатку ти відриваєш
рекомендацію на бюджет за третім
пріоритетом за спеціальністю як
призначено в витрачаємо апріорі тайти
таким чином і розумі ми чекаємо вже буду
ситуація cool і
якісь абітурієнти споживають ви
університети споживатимуть у максимальний
опція кістка конкретного університету
тари точно не могли б там на джа-джа
барани не споживають у число на та красиві
замки спеціальністю в тілі та в
такому випускаються й університет на ранок
мій візит житнього замовлення в принципі
і в тему владно поливає реформи eulogy
розпаду ллодра багато за молла нижчим і
по ви не
виду ти місця дріжджам але замула немає йому
мені висота там до 3 курс струменя по
потім саррот абітурієнти такому дуже
важливо було підло те не просто чоловікові
рамках конкретно початкового закладу вони
показали що ти входиш число найкраще
зате спеціальності і даний ви не
Тільки живий бог для універс атаки в Які
знаходиться в піратку їм шахара
буду прикладів державну фіскальної
служби опціях державну замовлення в
університеті фіскальну службу та
фіксованому винний курирується закладений
від цього я якихось кисть абітурієнти століття
якісь території антивіки тут і
подалася в такому в їх підкупі.
чоловіка для тіла початкового закладу ми вже
будуть рохан шукаю я не чекаю інших початкових
закладі особі
україни випад як від 3 до їжі привід для
складаємося і в цілому для абітурієнтів щоб
відразу метати 6 право брилу їм за
профанного нам бюджетні місця на піну
спрацював одним простим коло по ріверті
за вищим апріорі то ми зайдемо ми
перебуваємо особливо на рекомендації що
ціна за рахова на ніка піднесена балом
вони чекають обидва екшени до піднесених ебалами
нижню табуна за рахова на задок залишайся
перебуваємо і питала правою і тобі за
пропливала краще місць з числа tedx
на цих ти можеш претендувати на
бюджетний замок
на ньому